[拍手]
音楽院では
生徒会主催のビジネスコンテストか毎年のように回開催されてい
時に生徒会企画はビジョンばっかりだあのどう言われてしまうこともあります
ですが今日話をするのは
中1の時にその生徒会主催のビジネスコンテストに参加してそれをきっかけにビジネス
にもそうしていくことになった話です
本日は前半では僕自身が重工5年間でどのように変わることができたのかということ
後半ではその経験を踏まえて中高生がもっともっと外の世界に出ていくためにはどうし
たらよいのかんって言う僕なりのアドバイスをさせて頂ければと思っております
中学1年生の頃の写真を載せておきました
ここまでの市中港生活があっているんだなぁと思いつつも振り返ってみたら本当に様々
な経験をしてきたと思います
入学したころ中学受験をしたので勉強自体はまあそれなりに好きでした
ですけど他に熱中するようなことがなくて
あまり積極的なタイプでもありませんでした
その時に友達に一緒にやらないかと声をかけられたのが選挙改革のイノベーション
カップでしっ
その日自分で屋外た人は ai が旅行の計画をサポートスラグに
を考えました
様々な4本アプリの ai に伝えたらここに最適な旅行プランが出来上がるという
ものです
なんか ai がやってるって言うとまだが当時の僕たちにとってはなくすごいものが
できているんじゃないかという気持ちになりました
ただ4校4回でそもそも今やってる会社がすごくを見て栄養が使ったサービス帰って
いうこと自体もすごく難しいので今考えるとちょっとありえないなと思ってしまいます
その時の王スライドがこちらになります
まあデザインもちょっと今から取り替えてみるともうちょっと頑張れよーと思うんです
けれども
当時は右上にあるサンプル用の動画を撮り
鎌倉まで手がけたりだとか本当に一生懸命になりました
イノベーションアップは最終審査まではをてなかったんですけれども
当時の生徒会長のがたり家のビジネス関係のイベントに誘ってもらったりしていこう
いうクリエイティブなことを持ってやっていきたいな
そう思いました
その後も他のビジネス系なイベントに参加したりだとか
a してい
こういった新しい企画を考える同好会を立ち上げたりもしました
ですが自分の中で特に王子買ったのがこの青木起業家育成プロジェクトです
お見合いの式場ずを育てるという甲子園1で行われているこのプログラム派
起業家として必要な措置と学べるプログラムで即興のプレゼントかも
で鍛えられました
他にも実際にシリコンバレーを訪問して生きようの本番を見てその空気感を感じていき
たい
国内ネーミンちゃん企業訪問をしたり
意義を彼の大変な側面を見ながらも起業家みたいね氏がたもうそれはそれで面白そうだ
なと思わされた経験でしたよ
積極的でなかった中1の頃とは少しずつここから代わっていただけます
この青木溶解性プレゼントで僕は新たなキーパーソンちょっとやります
逗子開成高校の宮崎祐樹くんです
八鹿駅西武られんとれいにゃんだということでお互いに興味の方法性が見ており
仲良くなっていきました
彼はビジネスに関わることへの吸収とか半端なくこの先石ネスの世界を打っていく上で
本当に
頃強いない方になりました
あとに紹介する僕が作った2つのビジネスプランを変えと一緒に作ってい
青毛企業改正ことだけどの路コンバレー編集の最終日君
特にはどうしても忘れられない思い出があります
時間の令状が終わったようなシーンやが立っている
あったら面白そうなに自然の水泥先ほどの宮崎と
and 1人友人とでおもむろにあたりがしました
まあこういうある種の前にある形ができると言う
青木溶解していくべきとこれ形では強さだと思います
そんな新しいビジネスの話をしているとそれいいね
もっとこうしたらと話がどんどん弾んでい
本当にありそうなビジネスの形になっていきました
そうすると1番で行ける所へ連れていこうじゃないかという話になってほぼ徹夜で s
nest ランを1本仕上げました
いろんな白熱してなにがすごいものができるんじゃないかと行きたいなっ
眠さの議会は j アートマを働かせてい働かせターナよりの興奮は今でも忘れること
ができません
そうしてできたのがこちらセカンド方というサービスです
スーパーレーンでいる食材を剥いらはがした調理をして家で一手間加えられている状態
にしていたクマで配送してくれたりできる
帰り際に打ったりするっていうサービスです
まあ存在を買ってくるだけではサボりって思われじゃないそうそう思う人が多いを張っ
ていいしてい
開発しました
このサービスのメインターゲットの想定は共働き世帯でした
ある程度サービスの基本構想が固まった段階でとりあえず辞典的にサービスをやでる
ようじゃないかということで2日間年齢デイサービスの一部分
一部分である買い物代表を実施しました
引き輪式はプラウドファンディング到達し46,500円を集めることができました
たくさんもいいしてくださった方がいたのは本当に個人の考えです
その後チラシを作って武蔵小関根自前で小針
品を吐く制して10問を受けました
よく注文してくださったのはお友達が1人とチラシを見て注文し来なかった一般の方が
一人の ok
2人でした
少ないですけれども一般の方でも注文してくださった方がいたというのは僕にとって
受精に嬉しい点です
その後は5投手がいっぱい集まるような一面の通りも参加しました
そこで出会う社会の第一線で活躍されているお店の方々は本当に熱心で僕たちの話を
聞いてくれて
本気などはいつもたくさんいただきました
その中で現在で僕たちの利用を考えるとこのサービスを実現させるのは長所難しいもの
がある
結論に至りました
大人の方々が教えてくれる厳しい現実を見て中で僕たちは方針転換をすることになる
方針転換をし現在の制作を続けているのがこの
いいというアプリです
場でも宮崎とともに髪を進めています
このサービスは時間の方同様もことで風味ターゲットいっしょサービスです
浜端自体は特にか事務負担の問題など忙しいが良い
どうしてもうまくいかないということがおりがちです
そこで夫婦円満な環境だしている夫婦関係のメンテナンスというコンセプトで開発して
いるアプリになります
少々話が脱線しますけれども当時じゃないようにここで it 夫婦向けのサービスを
作ろうと思ったのは
夫婦にゆとりが生まれることでそれぞれのてぃいた彼の個性が生まれてい
それが子どもにも良い影響は大部分という宮崎の原体験があったからです
まだ開発中ではありますか良い子様2人に入れていただきと毎日
夫婦関係や日常生活に関する簡単な質問が相撲取るのでにそれに答えていただきます
解凍するとその他のかデーのケルピーたやその項目にまつわる記事などが見られるよう
になります
またパートナーに投融資た方が夫婦の相互理解が深まると反対した
質問はパートナーにその回答結果が共有されます
開業チェックがたまっていくとパートナーの補正がわかる分析が呈されます
その他にも夫婦間でいる gp 約ホームショベル機能なども検討しています
このサービスを作る上でも多くの大人の方々に協力していただいています
世代ならではの観点からさあ1
くっていることを評価していただきます
現在百貨店愛護スカートり有名な悪いさんと一緒にプロジェクトを進めています
大規模なサービスの金賞を行う際にファイル社員の方々に協力していただいたいっ
大人の目線からさまざまなアドバイスをいただいたりしています
また自分たちがサービスのメインターゲット層ではないため夫婦の方へのインタビュー
もかなり徹底して行なっています
ではここからはここよ経験に基づいて中高生がもとその世界でチャレンジしていくため
に集団と思ったことをお話します
この5年間僕はたくさんの起業家投資家の方とお話しさせて頂く機会を頂きました
こちらがそれなりの準備と覚悟で臨めば多くの大人は本当に熱心に答えてくださいます
中高生の経験の大変さをみなプレイのは小澤です
僕たちがセカンド方やね時間が出来たのも育めを流れる
助言が高いですし今でも多くの音だからサポートを頂きながら
自分のやりたいことをやっています
全然解決策をわからなかったことが大人に聞いてみたら一発で分かった
そんなことだってざらにあります
ですからをそれぞれを妻に立ち向かってください
だからといってその受講生見てのイベント等を否定しているわけではありません
実際にこのセット帰り道今からこのような舞台答弁を持ち始めたのでぜひそういった
ことをきっかけにしていて欲しいと思います
でもその世界を本当に突き詰めたい
問題はならばっ
ぜひ中校舎でもどんどん大人の世界に入って欲しいと思います
こうして音だといろいろ話していると高校生なるすごいで
成東よくいていただきます
このプレゼンを聞いて皆さんの分野は違いの
なんとか運命なことを聞いてんされた目じゃないでしょうか
僕はこりょう中高生バイアスやかかった状態と呼んでいます
僕たちが出て行こうとしているのは大人が調べの社会社会です
中高生レベルの完成度で満足してしまうのは
せ
頑張ったのにも絶えないと思いませんが
なのでぜひ大人でもなかなかできない
そう言われるレベルを目指していいプロなプロジェクトにあげてください
そこを目指すマイをセットしたい
出来上がるもののクオリティは格段に上がります
そして思いがけない危機やチャンスとの遭遇
それをその時はなんとも思わなかったような小さな出会いだ
その後の人生を大きく変えると僕は思っています
もし僕がついちゃうとき
友人に声をかけられていなかったら
もし合わず起業家育成プロジェクトにいけていなかった
そこで宮崎の中になっていなかっ
僕のその後の人生はまったく違ったものになっていたでしょう
柔軟剤が何柱印象を語っているんだとお思いかもしれません
ですが少なくとも5年前の僕は今このような答えで話しているような人ではありません
でした
考えてみれば奇跡的な事です
皆さんも空前の小さな出会いを逃さないように
ぜひ個人じゃ電気かもしれない
そう毎によりしてみてください
ポンティ fx のプレゼンなどで天気ない人がいるかもしれません
それくらいの雪は突然にやってくるものです
そして人生の転機をつかんだと思ったう
自分がその方コリン見たいのかという確定
そしていきたいと思ったならば行動を起こしてください
これまでいろいろとちょっと理屈っぽくお話をしました
ですが理論をあれこれと考えようには実戦の方が大事です
カシスソーダでよる試して山に行かなかったらその解説
壊してやりナース
チャレンジとはそれを繰り返しているはずです
ぜひ皆さんがチャレンジとかをどんどん外の次回を広げていただければ幸いですご清聴
ありがとうございました
[拍手]